vision residence just when we thought
the Super Bowl weekend couldn't get any
more exciting you surprised us with a
brand new MCU spinoff series Disney plus
we can't wait to find out what you have
in store for us and Wanda and vision too
of course
it looks like the Marvel power couple
will be welcoming twins into the world
and we can't wait to see how things play
out on the small screen this is so
amazing and nuts and cool the upcoming
spinoff series Wanda vision is setting
up the MC use future timeline in more
ways than one tons of new faces will
appear on top of a slew of familiar ones
three new members could be introduced
into the MCU two of those being Wanda
and visions twins keep watching to find
out who the third member is here's a
clue he's a member of the Young Avengers
Elizabeth Olsen and Paul Bettany are
back as Wanda Maximoff and vision
respectively but this time they'll be
entertaining fans of the MCU via Disney
Plus although little is known about the
spin-off series Wanda vision some major
hints have been dropped in the teaser
trailer fans are quick to point out that
Wanda seem to be pregnant with twins
it looks like Wanda and vision are
finally getting the happily ever after
they'd always dreamed of which is
strange since vision was destroyed by
Thanos in Avengers infinity war but even
then things aren't always what they seem
for starters the timeline of the show
seems to be on the fritz
the teaser jumped from era to era
showing Wanda and vision in some very
questionable outfits the most notable
one being Wanda's original Scarlet Witch
costume which many fans remember from
the comics this could be a hint that the
series will cover how Wanda came to be
the Scarlet Witch the show's timeline is
bound to jump from the past to the
present to the future which could result
in viewers watching Wanda and visions
twins go from babies to teenagers to
years we stolen these laws it's been
confirmed that actors kat dennings and
randall park are reprising their roles
as Darcy Lewis and Jimmy woo whereas
actor Tiana Paris is set to play Monica
Rambeau Kathryn Hahn has also joined the
production but her character has yet to
be released little else is known about
the cast but new information is bound to
follow in the means
let's find out which comic book series
Wanda vision is said to be based on we
got to do a deep dive into some comic
books that we haven't yet reference news
of the spin-off series made headlines
when Avengers and Game first premiered
in Los Angeles in 2019 it was here that
elizabeth Olsen revealed while speaking
with variety that Disney would use
dozens of comic books as inspiration for
the series
Wanda vision will take place in the 50s
60s 70s and 80s allowing it to cover
plenty of ground The Scarlet Witch first
appeared in the x-men number 4 comic
book in 1964 and the mutant hero would
go on to entertain readers for over 50
years
you will tear them apart the same can be
said about vision who made his comic
book debut in Avengers number 57 back in
1968 but it's more than likely that
Disney will take a page or two out of
the Young Avengers comic book series
seeing as a pregnant Wanda was showcased
in the teaser fans of the MCU are well
aware that Wanda and vision go on to
have a set of twin boys after briefly
retiring from the Avengers and setting
up shop in the suburbs but wait how did
a mutant and an Android manage to
procreate well that's where things get
complicated and slightly morose The
Scarlet Witch envisioned broke the mold
when they fell in love and eventually
tied the knot in the 70s they retreated
from their hero duties in the 80s which
is when Wanda's dubious pregnancy was
first announced but since her husband
couldn't possibly pass down any of his
DNA the pregnancy was a call for concern
as it turned out Wanda had unknowingly
used her altering powers to generate her
own pregnancy but this would only be
revealed after the twins were born
everything was going great until Wanda
and vision chose to return to the
Avengers I know you believe what you're
doing is right that's when a nanny was
brought in to watch over the twins
however the second Wanda focused on her
mission the twins would vanish into thin
air it was almost as if the twins
stopped existing the second their mother
wasn't around and as it turns out this
was very much the case the final
consensus was that Wanda had created the
twins by altering reality and once she
discovered this the twins vanished for
good
least for a little while but before we
reveal how Wanda's make-believe children
managed to become real-life people let's
find out whether or not these future
young Avengers will become main
characters in the series okay and let's
worry about how you get there
the Super Bowl marvel teaser had fans of
the MCU scratching their heads
some believe that wand division will
follow a linear timeline instead of
jumping between the past present and
future in the teaser it looks as though
Wanda and vision are experiencing a
time-lapse of some sort Wanda is greeted
by vision who says in a scene that looks
fresh out of the I Love Lucy sitcom but
things get heated when timelines jumped
like loose wires and Wanda is shown
answering a telephone on the TV so some
fans believe that the segment shown in
the teaser hint toward our heroes living
through an alternate reality of host to
a time shifting plot lines but other
fans aren't as convinced instead they
stand firm in believing that Wanda
vision will lay the foundation for the
live-action version of The Young
Avengers that's your favorite story
according to Nerdist the introduction of
twins Thomas and William will not be a
short-lived storyline or Easter egg but
rather a way of introducing a brand-new
slew of superheroes into the MCU and we
can't help but agree after all Disney
did clearly state that the MCU would be
expanding and introducing fresh
storylines and characters will help
writers create new Marvel movies which
has also been the goal for Disney lawn
division is all set to introduce Wanda's
mysterious babies but seeing as William
and Thomas don't actually exist this
could be a hard thing to do that's my
fault it would appear that Wanda is
going through life altering events in
the trailer which could be the result of
finding out that her twins were just a
figment of her powerful imagination in
the comics Wanda goes into a catatonic
state after finding out the truth about
her children but as it turns out Wanda's
twins weren't 100% fictional as their
minds did indeed exist our very strength
invites challenge challenge insights
conflict it said that Wanda gave William
and Thomas life by using two scattered
fragments of Matthysse toes so
whose essence has been shattered by
Franklin Richards
however with mefisto returned to life
the twin souls were reabsorbed back into
the villain destroying him from the
inside out then their souls reincarnated
into the bodies of two American kids
Thomas Shepard and William Kaplan that's
not what everyone else says the problem
with this storyline however is that
readers never did find out if Thomas and
William's souls were placed into
preexisting bodies or whether they went
back in time to be born into their
rightful bodies and raised by different
parents either way thanks Timothy snows
demise tommy Shepard and Billy Kaplan
were given physical form and each
long-lost twin was given a set of
powerful mutant powers which they
inherited from their mother I can't
control your fear Wanda vision could
very well be setting up the future of
the MCU by providing fans with the
origin stories of The Young Avengers so
instead of following Tommy and Billy
into adulthood the show might reveal how
these future Avengers came to be while
doing the same for other members of the
team or we could be introduced to the
estranged twins as they find out about
their true heritage and learn to harness
their powers according to the comics
both Tommy and Billy grew up in the New
York New Jersey area
but like most mutants things start to
get complicated for the twins when they
reach adolescence but there is Grace in
their failings I think you missed that
Thomas Shepard who eventually becomes
the superhero speed is the only child of
a divorced couple just like his uncle
Pietro aka
Quicksilver Tommy's powers revolve
around SuperSpeed Wanda's son even looks
like a carbon body of her late brother
silver hair and all then there's Billy
whose own powers don't kick in until he
randomly bumps into his mother Wanda
funny enough Wanda and Billy don't have
the slightest clue that they're related
at the time in the comics Billy gets
beat up by bullies after school and he
wanders past the Avengers mansion where
he passes out and his leader discovered
by the Scarlet Witch what is it
stay in me Wanda consoles him by
touching his head unknowingly activating
his repressed mutant powers but instead
of taking after his mom's twin brother
like Tommy Billy develops the same
powers as Wanda herself soon after Billy
finds out the truth about his heritage
and locates his twin brother he becomes
this superhero Wiccan and together they
become the backbone of the Young
Avengers this is not so bad we know for
a fact that Thomas and William will make
an appearance in Wanda vision after all
we do see a pregnant Wanda followed by
Wanda and vision standing over two
identical cribs we even see the babies
through their pacifiers up into the air
if the show does follow Tommy and Billy
into their teenage years there's a
chance that we will also encounter the
young Avenger old king bulking his
Wiccans boyfriend in the comics so
anything is possible oh and apparently
he's brought a guest Kevin who has been
the president of Marvel Studios since
2007 has confirmed that Marvel is
planting seeds for the Young Avengers
team and releasing Wanda vision could be
their way of hinting at what's to come
now that the Avengers appear to have
disbanded after the events of Avengers
endgame again that's irrigated what
would your news the end Marvel could be
working towards filling that spot with a
new band of superheroes the Young
Avengers will undoubtedly join the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the near
future and tons of new faces could light
up the big screen of course we know that
Wiccans speed and hooking will join the
roster of heroes but what about members
like Kate Bishop Cassie Lang miss Marvel
and Miss America nothing is clear at the
moment but we do note that a new era of
Marvel heroes could very well become a
reality I think we're finally getting to
tell those stories well Wanda vision
isn't the only Marvel spin-off that was
announced during the 20/20 Super Bowl
the Falcon and Winter Soldier and Loki
were also confirmed during the teaser
trailer while much of these projects are
being kept under wraps one thing is for
sure Marvel has a very bright future
before you go tell us which Marvel
spin-off you're most excited about in
the comments section below
and thanks for watching give this video
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
next time
you